انا بدي احمي اولادي بس انا اطلع
بعيلتك زايد مش مش ناقص يعني مش فاقد ولا
حدا هذا اهم اهم انجاز ممكن احققه في
الحرب هي واهم انتصار يعني انا حطلع ببيان
انتصار انه انا طلعت بعيلتنا بعد
الحرب انا اسمي احمد مهنا ابو الياس انا
سبت تل الهواء وسبت بيتي وجيت انا اربع
اولاد
معي تعرض بيتي كله لقصف راح بيتي بعوض
الله بدنا نطعم الاولاد بيجي بنعجن بجيب
طحين الوكاله سلتنا طحين بعجن لهم بق لهم
بخبز كمان على الحطب عن قلايه بحطها هيك
وبخبز لهم عشان نطعمهم لانه كنا نتغلب في
الاول في البدايه بالطحين نروح نصف على
المخابز نصف ظور اطلع له من الثلاثه الفجر
عشان احصل لي ربطه ويا عالم احصل او ما
احصل فكان كثير معاناه يعني بس بعد الطحين
الحمد لله نقدر نطعم يهم يعني وطعمهم انا
بطعم من ها الخبزات ست عائلات 27 نفر يعني
كل واحد ممكن يحص له رغيف اه بول بشتري
خشبه بحط على النار ونولع هي الحياه صعبه
مش سهله ونا ن طعميه ناس كانوا ماشيين
ستات من الباديه يعني صاروا يطلعوا
مستغربين قلت لهم اه بخبز ايش المشكله
وقالت لي بقول لهم بتعرف تعمل زي اللي انا
بعمله هذا الخبز اللي هو الخبز العيش يعني
اللي بينفخ قالت احنا بنعمل صاج قلت ل لا
بس هذا اسك قالت طب امانه اذوق واحد
اعطيتهم عجبهم يعني انه شعور حلو بتقوللي
طيب وين المدام قت المدام بتشرب قهوه على
الشط على الكورنيش وانا قاعد بشتغل لها
فصار يضحكوا يعني من المواقف الظريفه يعني
استغربوا كيف راجل قاعد بخبز وبعجن ويساوي
وين مراته هم متعودين في الباديه المراه
هي اللي بتعمل كل شي بس احنا اضطرينا لهيك
اضطرينا انه نصل للمرحله ها
[موسيقى]
اكثر موقف يعني كنا بالليل انا بنام زوجتي
بتكون صاحيه هي بتصحى انا بكون يعني صاحي
ن بت شيات عاملين لانه الاولاد نايمين
حطيناهم بالصالون قريب على الباب فانت
تسمعي صوت برا حركه اي همسه بالح ب تكون
مسيطره او مركزه ايش اللي بصير لو صحيت
تصحين بتقول لي في حركه في البرج اللي ج
طيب اطلع يا فلان في ناس بنزل على الدرج
ايش في بدهم يخصف البرج طيب هي الكلمه
لحالها انت ثلاثه الفجر تصحي الاولاد ايش
تعمل ايش تساوي تاخديهم تنزل على الدرج هي
معاناه كبيره اه لا كا خبر كاذب ارجعوا
ثاني ثاني يوم نفس الفكره وثالث يوم كنا
عايشين هذا الرعب اللي اللي كان مزعج كثير
يعني طلعت من بيتي في اول يوم المدام جتها
رساله من اخت لها بتشتغل في مؤسسه دوليه
تحكي لها انه بتقولوا لنا توجهوا جنوب
وادي غزه جهزت اغراضي لفيت في البيت هيك
اتطلع مش عارف شو بدي بس انه بتطلع فيها
اخذنا الاغراض اللي بنقدر ناخذها طبقت
الباب فبتقول لي سكروا بالمفتاح ليش ما
سكرتو والي صار اطلعت هيك قلت لها معوض
الله سكرت
الباب في احساس بقولون للواحد انا يعني
استعوضت ربي من هي اللحظه
لسه اول استخدام
ها بس مضطرين نحطها على
[موسيقى]
الحطب هذا الموقف اول ما عرف انه البيت
راح يعني ما فكر الب ق مافكر في
العصفورين كثير زعل عليهم حبيبي
يا بعوض الله اللهون طيور بالجنه ان شاء
الله ياطير هذا بعوضك في بدالهم ان شاء
الله
[موسيقى]
يا
احنا
مخلوقين احد شاعر
فينا لشي مش سهل ايش بدنا نضلنا عايشين
هيك لوقت ايش طب طب بدنا ناكل بدنا نشرب
طب بعد هيك مين سال فينا ما حد سال
[موسيقى]
فينا
ه